[Musique]
ils sont plus de 4400 femmes et hommes à
se préparer au défilé pédestre du
14-juillet différentes unités dépendante
de l'armée terre de la marine nationale
de l'armée de l'air de la gendarmerie
encore des sapeurs pompiers pendant
quatre jours ils se sont entraînés à
cette véritable opération un
entraînement avec cet objectif dégager
un sentiment particulier chez les
spectateurs
ce qui m'importe si vous voulez c'est
que le défilé dégage un sentiment de
force de puissance et de cohésion
ça se voit au combat mais ça se voit
aussi dans un exercice un peu technique
voilà comme l'ordre serré l'ordre serré
un exercice de base pour un militaire ce
sont les fondamentaux pour tous soldats
aspirants je vois déjà des gens qui
arrivent et qui se sont entraînés
c'est très clair voilà ce qui a
maintenant c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on
mette au point ce sont les réglages
c'est à dire qu'il faut que les les
blocs soit compact 1 que les distances
entre les unités soient bien respectées
et ça ça demande de l'entraînement
appartenant à l'unité du sous marin
nucléaire d'attaqué émeraude le
quartier-maître première classe romain
va défiler pour la première fois il
vient de terminer une opération de huit
mois mené dans la région indo pacifique
le défilé une bouffée d'air frais pour
ces marins premièrement c'était
impressionnant de voir de voir tout ce
monde et il a toujours des petits
réglages à faire mais on est sur la
bonne voie et on sera plus que prêt le
jour j
le défilé pour le 14 juillet sur les
champs-elysées devant le président de la
république c'est à la salle d'honneur de
par notre mission tron vient de terminer
c'est alors à la reconnaissance de la
nation à ses armes et j'en suis très
fier dans le ciel de paris 90 cet
appareil participeront au défilé 2021
hélicoptères avions chasseurs différents
aéronefs de l'armée de l'air de la
marine nationale de la gendarmerie ou
encore de la sécurité civile avec une
organisation particulière le défilé qui
est constitué d'un ensemble de
patrouille qui vont attendre dans
l'ouest parisien
qu'on leur donne le top départ est bien
se rejoignent petit à petit sur un axe
qui est l'acte de défiler et c'est bien
par le respect des altitudes le respect
des vitesses le respect des trajectoires
le respect des horaires
le respect des procédures radio que la
sécurité aérienne est garanti pour son
deuxième défilé du 14 juillet le
commandant nicolas pilotera un mirage
2000d le ravitailleur va ouvrir la voie
en se mettant à leur est en suivant
scrupuleusement une trajectoire etc
après là où j'interviens mois avec
maillet messi au rafale est derrière et
et messi 2000d ou et bien à mon
initiative va bien je ferai resserré le
dispositif pour assurer parfaitement
l'alignement et la formation lors du
défilé comme chaque année les alpha jet
de la patrouille de france ouvriront le
défilé suivi des avions des troupes à
pied des hélicoptères et des troupes
motorisées et montées